so let's just have a fun conversation
about poop okay because how else does
one really talk about this it strikes me
in our trying to report this story
photograph this story and write about it
that one of the big issues is it's a
hard thing to talk about for a lot of
people this is a problem that largely
has been solved in our country for a
hundred years and so very hard to to
kind of clear that first hurdle of just
raising awareness you know in the
developing world a case of diarrhea is
life-threatening and you know whereas if
it happens to one of our kids maybe they
miss a day of school so the world is
full of all of these great causes
important causes why this issue I think
for me as I started to look at issues of
extreme poverty and and wanted to get
involved water and sanitation just under
it was like it undergirded everything it
was just so massive and and I didn't
hear anybody talking about it and and
then as I as I learned about it I it's
just endlessly fascinating and vastly
complex and there's no kind of one
silver bullet that's going to fix it and
so what happens a lot of times as we'll
start with a water loan they were there
fronted the money because they're
already paying for for water on a daily
basis they're paying but to use a public
bathroom right they're paying every day
to do that and so if you loan them the
money it's actually works out to be
about the same thing that they're paying
and and then within a couple years
they're free and clear and they've got
water in their house and they've got a
latrine so you talked about when you go
to India and you're here these people
and their stories are moving what kind
of stories are they telling you this is
probably five years ago this was in
Haiti we helped bring water to this
village that hadn't had it and this
young 13 year old was was no longer
gonna have to scavenge for water and go
on these water collections and she was
putting in three to four hours a day I
said what are you gonna do with all this
extra time you're gonna have more time
for homework
and she looked at me like she cuz I
don't need more time for homework I'm
the smartest kid in my class so I was
just like all right hotshot what are you
gonna do with this extra time and she
looked at me and she said I'm gonna play
yeah and it just buckled me because I
went you know like that's these kids
shouldn't be burdened with these things
you know and and and this extreme
poverty is this tremendous burden and
whether you're scavenging for water or
whether you're a little girl who's
waiting for it to get dark so that you
can go out and defecate you know just
and put yourself at risk you know
because that's a whole other aspect to
it is there are these you know predatory
men who are waiting for these girls
those kids should be playing that's what
they should be thinking about that's
what our kids think about so the UN I
think has tried to say that by 2030 they
want to make it you know goal to really
not have open defecation do you think
there's any way that you know the world
could come close to that that's only 13
years I know okay I think it's happening
so rapidly I mean the last two and a
half decades two and a half billion
people have been lifted out of poverty
so we're really trending in the right
direction and we'll continue to do so
and then in terms of engaging there are
all levels of engagement whether it's
you know donating or you know you can go
to water.org and there are multiple ways
you can donate and help I think for the
takeaway from me is because our loan
programs are what we call water credit
is we has been working so well it's a
very positive experience and that's what
I would want your your readers to know
is that is that there are these
solutions that work
[Music]
[Music]
you